[Music]
well it only makes sense that we
transition from dead bodies to anybody
our cooking confidence coach Nanny puppy
is back in studio thanks to Chapman
Automotive you Kendall that's the
lead-in we wanted right that's the one
you wanted uh Chapman Automotive uh
sponsors this segment we appreciate them
and today we are learning how to make
balanced back to school lunches yeah so
talk about your children but at the end
of the day this is a really really
serious topic a very serious topic so no
jokes today no jokes stay away from the
jokes no the the truth is is that as a
parent or a caregiver to your children
when they go off to lunch you have one
true purpose and do you know what that
purpose is is to help them get through
the afternoon right and if they happen
to have math or signs in the afternoon
and you've given them what I call
lovingly gas station food which are bags
of chips and cupcakes and things that
are not nutritionally dense you are
keeping them from learning so what you
give them really helps them learn spring
power it really is and I just want to
say if you don't believe that your gut
and your brain are connected here's two
examples of that number one you drink
alcohol what happens to your brain
immediately right you drink coffee you
wake up you say oh I'm you know I'm
sluggish I'm gonna go get a coffee and
all of a sudden your brain wakes up so
there is a connection between gut health
and brain health so this is why what you
give your kids at lunch is critical and
you have some vegetables and other
things here that really can contribute
positively to that right so starting
with what we give them for fruit so this
time of year you want all kinds of
melons Stone fruits they're filled with
water Mother Nature really knew what she
was doing when she gave us these fruits
during the hot months I'm going to put a
little salt on do you like salt on
watermelon I do take a bit do you like
it yes I will now it's the best okay
there you go it really kids actually
really love it and then you want to go
to color so all of this color look at
this grapes these sweet little tiny bell
peppers are not spicy they are
absolutely wonderful and sweet and
beautiful and then as we turn to the
winter of course then Citrus comes
Mother Nature knew what she was doing a
little heirloom tomatoes for lunch and
you can put all of this in a little bit
of hummus so I'll show you just a little
bit of that hummus which actually really
is good it's protein look at these
heirloom carrots yeah that's crazy for
that yeah the ecomas and this is roasted
ikama if you will and this is from
dinner last night but it is so delicious
with salt and uh paprika and then cheese
sticks are great and let's go into
fermented foods because this is the true
gut health so believe it or not kids are
so overdosed in Sugar that they really
are sick of that and so what you would
be surprised to know is they love these
fermented pickles and this brand right
here called Bubbies coincidentally I
don't own it but it this is one of the
few Brands where the pickles are
fermented and not pickled and the
difference is this has no vinegar in it
so look for a brand that only has salt
and water and spices because that's
fermented because because fermented
foods are a probiotic they're the best
thing for your gut and if you want your
kids to learn better in the the
afternoon give them a little bit of
sauerkraut or Korean kimchi which is
very spicy a high schooler eat that not
a little complimentary but they learn
very well yeah they learn very very well
in the afternoon and they really do aid
in digestion yes and you know what you
can dip all of these vegetables these
little baby cucumbers are great you can
eat the skin so you can just send them
like this or in little slices also with
a little bit of salt on this if you can
see it so this is what and also you know
what I love in my um uh sauerkraut
what's that sunflower seeds and you can
send sunflower seeds to
um to school because it's not a nut it's
a seed and seeds are not you know
allergenic or you don't get allergies
from seeds so we don't we have just a
little bit of time left let's get to
dessert thank you for that okay
do deserve a deserted school so this is
a sunflower butter again made with
sunflower seeds we're going to spread
that on let the kids help you make this
then we're going to put some raspberries
right on there then we're going to smash
them down like that let the kids help
you yeah and then what you're going to
do is douse this if you will with this
melted chocolate and by the way you
could even use blueberries you want to
throw a few blueberries absolutely I'm
going to reach over here under there or
under there you go and then you throw
this into the refrigerator and then the
next day you just put in a Ziploc bag
and send it off to school because the
chocolate melted is actually gets hard
and you can send this as a treat and
immediately and then the chocolate plus
The Raspberries makes it very sweet and
that's it raspberry on top I love you
here you go awesome love it it looks
beautiful too Nanny Bobby thanks so much
for joining us you can check out Nanny
Bubby's kitchen and Garden on social
media you wanted to say together spread
love like butter butter go to
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
Chapman Automotive for sponsoring this
segment more Las Vegas now after this
break